still able to go out there and give
their teams opportunities to go out
there and win and that's exactly what
zach has done since donning that astro
uniform this season in 10 starts he has
six quality starts the record is 4-1 and
the era 3.77 swag and a miss frankie
starts the game off with a strikeout oh
a sharp break right at the end no chance
for bets here's justin turner
let's fall into center field slicing
straw on the move near the wall puts it
away right in front of the wall
nice catch by straw for out number two
two outs and nobody on max muncie the
second baseman will stand in swag and a
miss frankie strikes out muncie a one
two three start to this game 33 year old
clayton kershaw makes his 11th start
this season those six wins good for
third in the national league have an
impressive year again
and he is throwing more sliders than
fastballs for the first time in his
career this one one
grounds one to short there's gavin lux
for out number one with pujols coming
off of the bag to grab it tucker 1-2
kershaw comes back home and strikes him
out with a curve falling into the zone
two up two down for clayton kershaw
coming in here
fredman with a ground ball on one hop to
third turner picks it up throws to first
there's chris taylor zach grenke has
reached the 3 000 inning plateau he
becomes just the seventh pitcher in the
wild card era to get to 3 000 innings
pitch 135th pitcher of all time
as taylor pops one towards the
astros dugout guriel makes the play
leans up against the dugout with luis
garcia and christian javier bail it out
good job getting to that
dugout wall and finding that place and
making sure that catch
so now two outs the base is cleared and
for the third consecutive home stand the
astros will face albert pujol sharply
hit diving stop by alex bregman and he
gets up to make the play on albert pools
julie guriel leads off the second for
the astros
he's been houston's best hitter this
year
goes after the first pitch pops it foul
pujols over to make the catch
and jordan alvarez coming up on 1-2
he strikes out again her shot getting in
with a curveball second strike out of
the game for kershaw two out nobody on
carlos correa coming up
softly bounced left side there's muncie
over there in the shift and another
quick inning kershaw sits him down on
seven pitches six up six down for granky
and kershaw top of the third inning both
pitchers
very efficient through the first two
innings no base runners yet greinke has
a couple of strikeouts just 20 pitches
so far there's a swing and a miss as
zach grenke picks up another strikeout
that's three strikeouts for the first
seven hitters one away in the third
fly ball center field mile straw coming
in kyle tucker it's gonna be strong who
cuts across tucker for the final out of
the inning kershaw tonight he's gone six
up six down her shot comes downhill
a sharp roller to short picked up by
gavin lux
out of there by pujol
delivers an o2 to straw
on the ground to lux who's been busy
[Applause]
martine maldonado coming up one two
he got him with a perfectly placed
fastball
nine up nine down for granky and kershaw
right into the middle innings in houston
the dodgers about to get their second
look at granky with bets to lead it off
and he takes a four pitch walk greggy
thought he had kissed the corner
instead betts becomes the first base
runner of the game for either team a
lead-off walk for betts here in the
fourth justin turner whose bat has
slowed down of late he flied to center
in his first stat back four petrock from
matt stope in the inning two and two on
turner grinky comes home turner waits on
it swats it to right center field
towards the gap in the wall and gone
they kept on flying
turner with a two-run shot and the
dodgers strike first
this one approximately the same swing
but he does get full extension kind of a
deceptive swing as far as where the
power is concerned because he meets it
right at the apex of the swing and that
ball back spins right out of there
max muncie picks on the first pitch uh
falling to right field that kyle tucker
has to go down to the ground and make a
nice play for that ball was really
diving quickly and tucker
makes the play for out number one here's
tucker
kershaw has faced 71 consecutive lefties
now without an extra base hit
that's a big hit the astros have their
first hit of the game as kyle tucker
puts one off the wall in right he's
gonna get to second base a one out base
runner for the astros the first extra
base hit of the season by a lefty
against clayton kershaw proud got
himself a hanging breaking ball and he
turned on it now alvarez will come to
the plate two nothing dodgers bottom of
the fifth the two two to alvarez
breaking ball call strike three a slider
fourth strike out of the game for
kershaw that's a first down to the fifth
two nothing dodgers top of the sixth
inning at minimate park barnes flight
out to center his first time
called third strike outside corner
austin barnes
calm looking
now turner two out nobody on in the
sixth
turner to left center field he's got
both hits
it was one for his previous 28 coming
into the game
it takes a walk here back to back to our
base runners
now they go here it comes ball four to
load him up
three consecutive two out base runners
for the dodgers and chris chandler will
bat with the bases loaded base is loaded
and taylor swats a liner sinking into
center and pastel
t-rex coming to score chris taylor with
a two-run
four consecutive two out base runners
for the dodgers not hit hard but
beautifully or the advantage when you
get the runners they can lead off big
smiles on the face of chris taylor and
why not
so kershaw and the dodgers now have a
four to nothing lead
sharply hit base hit for austin barnes
lux headed for third the throws cut off
the dodgers have runners at the corners
with one out and mookie betts coming up
ooh that ball's overthrown
takes a look at say that gives martin
out of the chance but lux is in there
safely and it's five nothing bregman
will lay things off castro's looking for
base runners more than anything else
right now it's the only way they'll get
back in it delivers and this one's hit
well
left field and deep going back and it's
out of here
a home run for bregman is sixth and the
astros are on the board it's his second
career home run against kershaw it's now
five to one
and strikes him out looking
three of the five k's for kershaw have
been courtesy of eurodon alvarez two
gone in the seventh first hit tonight
for correa chaz mccormick is the batter
oh two
kershaw strikes him out a slider drops
out of the zone and gets a swing in a
minute for emmanuel this is his tenth
appearance
that is ball four and he's walked in a
run
brady gets an rbi as smith comes home
and the dodgers lead 6-1 and a former
dodger farmhand andre scrub faces loaded
two out nowhere to put austin barnes as
the 3-0 flies home and another bases
loaded walk another run is in and it's
7-1 inside him right from the very
beginning of the inning in between
innings even that's the fourth
consecutive walk the third with the
bases loaded and they lead at 8-1
seventh walk tonight for the dodgers
kershaw is going to go back out there
for the bottom of the eighth inning and
so the lead off and on maldonado bounces
one deluxe gives him another chance it
goes six four three
and just like that kershaw isn't out
away from completing eight innings
he's recorded and out in the eighth
inning for the first time in a regular
season game since
and not even kershaw given this context
can grimace at that
seven and two thirds returning to
houston
an emphatic performance from clayton
kershaw leaves with an 8-1 lead
joe kelly showered with booze from the
astros fans as he's announced as the new
pitcher for the dodgers altuve is over
three two is two one
is crack gently to third there's turner
low throw big by muncie
muncie leading off third taylor off
second peters at first one out in the
ninth
lux hits it sharply to second oh two
bays there and they get the outage
second but that's all lux can really fly
build his choice and he gets an rbi out
of it so it's 9-2 now set at the belly
the pitch to correa swung on and missed
strike three and the dodgers win it 9-2
the dodgers improved their record to 30
and 18
and remain within a half game of the
first place san diego padres